onward here we go yo co its mornin outta
here and st. Louis man mornin and that's
a great name and that's an I mean that's
obviously a name you got to use before
noon and uh and that's got to be great
because there's got to be just peaceful
after that nobody bothering you onward
brother I would just pin you up cuz are
you talking about that ice cream machine
in McDonald's man I used to work up
there they canned me and I'll say the
truth about that thing man it's always
working it's just nobody wants to clean
it so they just tell you it's broken all
the time if you want some ice cream you
want to get that sundae you just tell
them straight up look imma talk to your
district manager I know that thing works
and I guarantee you man don't fire that
boy up for you but then you got to be
careful because they probably going to
spit in it
mmm so remember that the next time you
hittin that late-night McDonald's don't
let them pull that [__] on you dang
they always do it and how much spit
that's the question it really pops into
your brain like a like a damn vulture
with a handful of uh you know warm
marbles I mean that's the thing that's
you know how much you know if they drop
one little you know about a 19th of an
ounce or something over to the edge I
can handle it boy but if they do all you
know if they clear the throat I'm out we
get that's the thing McDonald's I mean
here's the thing this is a great time
for McDonald's to finally fire up the
the ice cream machines all these [__]
can't be off all of them can't be off
McDonald's are getting lazy they
fighting at Popeye's Chicken they got
peace but every now and then somebody
gets choked out over there
angry about the Lord Rocha I'm telling
you it's all turning into the WWE and
it's beautiful it's beautiful you can
have everybody next thing you know it's
gonna be you know crusty the crab is
gonna be running for office you're gonna
have a someone's gonna give birth to a
damn watermelon it's all merging This Is
It this is the time this is the time for
somebody to just pull the damn reach any
it reach into your do you can this is
the time you could do all kind of stuff
anything do what somebody do a backflip
off a damn Wendy's kids are learning
baseball on slanted fields okay it's a
new era where anything is possible and
we got it and I'm happy to be here with
you doing it all right let's take
another call good luck out there man
yeah I'm gonna tell them I'm a
threatened that district manager imma
hit him with that slide in the DM okay
cuz I know they they got that Sunday
superintendent and he's he knows that I
scream switch and I roll up every time I
said damn which an hour oh it's broke oh
we can't get it to uh turn it on jack
okay I'm sorry sir we out on our arm
turn it on
I want the Sunday and I want a little
second nutty nuts with it okay
then little freakin little bitty damn
look like you could barely get them
stuck in your teeth them little nut
nuggets I want the I want two packs it
in batches and I want it all or nothing
at all
turn on the sundae maker y'all in there
laughs and thinking you just all you
gonna make all night is little
cheeseburgers and this and that I want
six happy meals boy I want
[__] I know what y'all doing in there
y'all back there hiding [__] eating
them nighttime it griddles being risky
well look here grimace the Menace turn
it on turn on the sundae maker people
driving across town to get a damn sweet
cold frozen icy nighttime cupped snack
and you've got the audacity to just but
I don't we are there are oh it's all I'm
sorry to tell you but no I'm sorry to
tell you but I'll draw it Popeyes
chicken sandwich on the wallet is
fraggin McDaniels
and rays straight h-e-l-l-o Angra turn
it on I'm sorry man it's just makes me
mad boy it makes me mad so that's that
first call right there uh and that's the
truth if you want the facts you threaten
that district manager almost a slot in
here diem all right yeah thanks for
watching that video right there that was
a beautiful little segment I think but
of course i'm partisan to myself but you
can move on to another video right now
you can check on this video or on this
video that's two different options and
you can also subscribe to the channel
check on a new video subscribe to the
channel check subscribers curse card